before write an actual data step
can compile and execute your program
without creating a data set
this enables you to detect the most
common errors and saves you development
time
a simple way to test a data step is to
specify the keyword underscore null
underscore as the data set name in the
data statement
when you submit the data step no data
set is created but compilation or
execution errors are written to the log
after the values of the variables are
read and verified
after correcting errors you can replace
underscore null underscore with the name
of the data set that you want to create
this way you will get the error report
without wasting much time in processing
the wrong code
in the next screen we will discuss the
use of put statements to avoid data
errors
one source of program errors is not
apparent you can use put statement to
examine variable values and print your
own message in the log
for diagnostic purposes you can use if
then else statements to conditionally
check for values
for example consider the program shown
if you are sure that the variable code
in the input file can normally have
either one or two as a value you can use
a conditional statement to find out
whether the variable gets populated by
the correct value
in this if then else statement if the
variable code gets a value which is
neither one or two
it justifies that the program has
undergone an execution error and hence
the program flow will enter the else
part of the conditional statement
here we have used the put statement to
print a message which in turn acts as a
hint for the user
in the next screen we will discuss the
third type of errors that can occur in a
program
the category of errors is logical
programming errors
as per the standard definition a mistake
in a program's source code that results
in incorrect or unexpected behavior is
called a logical programming error
you can note that the definition refers
to logical programming error as a
mistake and not an error
the reason behind this is that the
category of error is neither caught in
the compilation phase nor in the
execution phase
these are the bugs which are introduced
in a program due to incorrect
programming practices
in the example shown
coded is the variable which gets the
values from the input file loan
this variable further decides the type
of loan as fixed or variable but instead
of using the variable coded in the if
statement the programmer has used code
which is another variable in the data
set as the variable name
this program will be compiled with no
errors and also run successfully without
any error or warning message in log
but the output will be incorrect
this is a logical error
these types of errors can be avoided
only by carefully coding the program